a
?
I WANTED TO BRING IN, IF WE CAN;
a
JOAN BISKUPIC WHO IS BACK WITH
US, AND JUST LIKE YESTERDAY, YOU
WERE IN THE COURT AGAIN TODAY A;
a
COMING DOWN, AND TAKE US INSIDE;
YOU SAW.
>> YEAH.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO SOUND SO
BREATHLESS, AND I DID ZIP OVER
HERE.
AGAIN, THIS TIME, IT WENT FOR ;
a
MORE THAN AN HOUR, AND WHAT IS ;
RIGHTS VERSUS LGBTQ INTERESTS, ;
a
CASE AND RIGHTS IN AMERICA WERE
DRAWN BY TWO JUSTICES SITTING
RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER.
THEY ARE ALL ARRAYED UP THERE O;
a
THE MAHOGANY BENCH, AND YOU HAD;
JUSTICE NEIL GORSUCH BEGIN BY ;
a
TALK ABOUT THE RELIGIOUS RIGHTS
AT ISSUE HERE FOR A WOMAN WHO ;
a
.
WHAT SHE STRESSED, SHE WOULD NO;
a
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON THE ;
FORECLOSE THAT OPTION BASED ON ;
a
TO ARTICULATE SPEECH.
SO EVERYTHING THAT JUSTICE
GORSUCH DREW OUT AS HE PRESENTE;
a
HIS SIDE OF THE CASE, THE
WINNING SIDE OF THE CASE HAD TO;
a
HE TALKED ABOUT INSTANCES WHEN ;
THE COURT HAD SAID THAT, NO,
STUDENTS COULD NOT BE FORCED TO;
a
SALUTE THE FLAG, AND NO,
GOVERNMENT COULD NOT STOP THE ;
a
E
REFERRED TO HERE INCLUDING THE
VETERANS PARADE THAT WANTED TO
KEEP OUT BANNERS AND MARCHERS ;
a
WHO WERE GOING TO OUT THE GAY
RIGHTS, AND THAT IS CONTEXT THAT
HE DREW HERE, AND IN PART TO GET
AHEAD OF THE DISSENTER SITTING
RIGHT NEXT TO HIM WAS ABOUT TO
SAY, AND HE REMINDED THE ;
a
E
IN 2020, AND THAT IS A CASE
WHERE HE WAS WITH THE MAJORITY ;
a
WORKPLACE.
SO, HE WANTED TO CAREFULLY ;
a
PRECLUDED HERE.
THEN WHEN IT WAS TIME FOR ;
a
THE PART OF THE DISSENTERS, AND;
THE THREE LIBERAL JUSTICES AS
YOU LAID OUT, AND SHE SAID, THIS
CASE IS NOT ABOUT SPEECH, BUT I;
a
IS CONDUCT AND STATUS.
IT IS ABOUT ALLOWING A WEBSITE ;
a
COME HERE.
SHE DREW A CONTRAST TO ALL THAT
JUDGE GORSUCH HAD LAID OUT OVER
SEVERAL MINUTES AS HE HAD OPENED
THE PROCEEDINGS WITH DETAILING
WHAT THE JUSTICES HAD DONE IN
THIS CASE BY SAYING LOOK AT HOW;
a
SHE REFERRED TO THE MOST RECENT;
HISTORY, AND SHE SAID LOOK AT ;
a
HOW MUCH HAS CHANGED IN JUST ;
JUSTICE KENNEDY SHE REFERRED TO
SAID THAT RETAILERS AN
BUSINESSES CANNOT EXCLUDE ;
a
INDIVIDUALS JUST BECAUSE OF ;
AGAIN, SHE WAS REMOVING THIS ;
a
WHICH GORSUCH WAS CASTING IT, ;
COLORADO, IT COULD LEAD TO OTHE;
a
SHE INVOKED HAD TO DO WITH ;
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ERA IN WHICH I;
a
AND THINK IT WAS A BARBEQUE
STAND WOULDN'T SERVE BLACK ;
a
ALLOW THEM TO COME TO THE WINDOW
OF THE ESTABLISHMENT, AND SHE ;
a
WAS THE FACTS OF THE CASE WERE
AND THE LAW AT ISSUE, AND THE ;
a
SOTOMAYOR WAS READING THE ;
HEAD TOWARD HER AS OFTEN ;
a
I AM SURE HE WAS QUITE FIRM IN
WHAT HE BELIEVED AND QUITE FIRM
IN THE MAJORITY THAT HE WAS ABLE
TO GET FOR THIS CASE TO SIDE
WITH THIS WOMAN WHO I SHOULD
REMIND EVERYONE HAS NOT IN ANY
WAY BEEN SANCTIONED BY THE STAT;
a
BROUGHT THIS CASE IN WHAT IS
KNOWN AS PREENFORCEMENT ;
a
SO IN SO MANY WAYS, THIS CASE
WAS KIND OF CREATED OUT OF THE ;
a
FACTS THAT DON'T QUITE FULLY
EXIST YET, AND THAT IS ANOTHER ;
a
THING THAT JUSTICE SOT
OTOMAYOR
POINTED UP.
AND SHOULD I GO TO THE NEXT CASE
WHEN THE CHIEF STARTED THE TALK.
>> YOU WERE THE ONE THERE. ;
a
T
I PLAYED OUT ON, YOU KNOW, SAME;
a
OWNER OF THE ESTABLISHMENT WHO
JUST FEELS LIKE SHE HAS A RIGHT,
SHE HAS A FREE SPEECH RIGHT NOT;
a
TO ADOPT THE MESSAGE OF A SAME
SEX COUPLE, AND IT IS ALL PART
OF THE CULTURE WARS, AND A QUICK
PS ON THAT, AND WHEN SOTOMAYOR
WAS TALKING ABOUT WHY THE COURT
WAS SO PROFOUNDLY WRONG, SHE ;
a
REFERRED TO THE KIND OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT GAYS AND ;
a
LESBIANS FACE RIGHT NOW, AND TH;
KINDS OF, YOU KNOW, MOVEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE STATES;
a
ALLOW DISCRIMINATION AGAINST GAY
RIGHTS, AND SHE SAID AT THIS ;
a
KIND OF TIME WHAT DOES THE ;
?
IT SHRINKS BACK FROM DUTY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE, AND INSTEAD, ;
a
RIGHTS ARE NOT IN NEED OF ;
PROTECTION, AND TO JUST CLOSE ;
a
OUT THE DRAMA OF THAT, AND THEN;
S
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION WAS WRONG
TO TRY TO PROVIDE LOAN
FORGIVENESS TO MILLIONS OF
BORROWERS IN THE WAKE OF COVID,
AND IN THAT CASE, FIRST OF ALL,
WHETHER THERE WAS A REAL ISSUE
IF THE SIX REPUBLICAN STATES TO;
a
HE BRUSHED BACK CONCERNS THERE ;
WHETHER MISSOURI EVEN COULD DO ;
a
HE HAS A BRISK VOICE AND TONE
THAT IT WAS IN CONTRAST
CERTAINLY TO JUSTICES GORSUCH
AND SOTOMAYOR AND HE CUT TO THE
CHASE, AND HE SAID THERE WAS AN;
a
MISSOURI TO BRING THIS CASE, AN;
WHEN HE GOT TO THE NUB OF THE
WHOLE THING, HE SAID SOMETHING
THAT WILL HAVE REVERBERATIONS IN
SO MANY AREAS OF REGULATION AND
PROTECTION FOR PEOPLE THAT ;
a
GOVERNMENT WANTS TO PROTECT IN
ENVIRONMENT, STUDENT LOANS, ;
a
BEYOND WHAT CONGRESS WOULD HAVE
WANTED TO DO AT ALL IN THIS ;
a
THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION
WORKING UNDER EMERGENCY ;
a
T
FORGIVEN UP TO $20,000. ;
a
DISSENT SAID, LOOK AT WHAT THIS
COURT IS DOING IT.
IT IS NOT QUITE READING STATUTE;
a
CORRECTLY, THE CHIEF HAS PICKED;
SUIT THE MAJORITY'S INTERESTS,
AND NOT READING IT AS A WHOLE, ;
a
AND TALKED ABOUT THE OTHER ;
E
FINA
-- HERS WERE THE WORDS OF THE
OPINION OF A DIFFERENT COURT ;
a
11:00 A.M., CHIEF ROBERTS SAID,
THAT IS IT FOR T